You've just seen how to step over each of these lines. But it didn't really
show us where the program misbehaved. The hard part goes on in this
countSyllables method. So we want to get inside it. For that we need to use the
second step button, the step into button. Let me restart the program and do
just that. Here we are again at the first line of the program, we enter the
input again, we step over the constructor, and now, going to hit the step into
button, and that opens up the Word class. Then we have to look around a bit to
find the arrow. We're right now, here. Now we can keep stepping, and that gets
us through the lines of countSyllables. So the point is, you use step to stay
within the same method, and step into to go inside a method. Now all that
stepping can get tedious and sometimes it's better to set more break points and
run the program at full speed until one of them gets hit. Let's practice that.
You see this line where it says count plus plus? Set a break point by clicking
here and now go ahead and restart the program. You'll hit the first break point
in main. When you hit it, click the Continue button. So that your program
continues at full speed. Supply the same input, and then your program will wake
up at this break point. Hit Continue again and keep doing that, and tell me how
many times you get the this break point.